I think I'm going to do it, right? >> No. No. No. >> Because
the damages, right, to my reputation are
>> are terrible. I feel terribly damaged. >> HE'S
NOT EVEN SELLING IT. THIS ISN'T THE LINE. YOU'RE TOTALLY PSYCHOTIC.
YOU. He's already There's nothing left to do. Brogan was like
trying to fundraise for her rent and crying about how hard streaming
is and how she's not going to make it. You guys were gleeful
about that.
>> I read this last night and I I said, "This seems like
something someone might want to address." >> So it says,
"Quick daily reminder that Ethan from H3 is likely a who has
his own children." It's a comment. Funny. Everybody's laughing.
>> The the Destiny thing about Ethan and his kids, that
was one of those where I was like, "Oh, man. I think I I stepped
too far out with this one." I'm sorry to Ethan and Ethan's family
for
putting that nasty Destiny comment out there. I felt like it
was an okay thing to do based on the point I was making, but
it gross shouldn't be spread like that. So let me tell you a
little story.
The second iDubbbz stopped talking about
happened to coincide
when I took into my um service some fine Canadian um defamation
lawyers that sent a letter to Anisa
>> and uh Ian demanding
a retraction
and a halting of the defamatory statements that I my children
>> He's apologized. >> Yeah, but the damage is done.
>> So this apology was not because I see people [snorts]
they're taking this to mean that you threatened them and that
in response he's apologizing. >> No, he's just doing talks.
>> Oh, okay. >> They're desperate to prevent litigation.
>> Mm. Gotcha. >> And they've preemptively apologized
out of pure um patheticness.
>> I think Nicholas, how I how I'd say I describe his thought
process right now going into this stream is he knows Ethan's
done something really bad. He basically wants to create the permission
structure to distance further from Ethan Klein if Ethan Klein
doesn't like apologize and reverse course.
But if Ethan Klein does apologize, he does not want to be left
on the outside.
So he's going to still sweep in this stuff where he can. And
then I would expect on the Adam stuff he's maybe going to go
a little harder, but we'll see. It's Okay, so I do want to say
I don't agree with what's being said in this um comment here.
Uh but I I'm putting it on screen because I think it should be
addressed because it's a big bold accusation that's very [__]
up.
So he's saying like, "Hey, look, Destiny's calling you a Why
aren't you talking about this?" That was the intent. I don't
Again, he leaves it on the screen for a a long amount of time,
I believe. Um I don't know how long, but I I think we pointed
it out and then eventually explains, "Oh, by the way, I disavow."
But that's the point. Like Destiny made and he's asking why Ethan's
not responding to it. That's that's that's what's happening there.
He's saying in the stream that he doesn't agree with that. In
large Why does that make no sense? Is he like is he short-circuiting?
Is this guy okay? Did that make Did what he say
Did what he said make any sense?
What did he just say?
He said "Adam's doesn't make sense." But then he explains what
Adam was saying and that makes perfect sense. >> hard joke
that makes no sense. >> What doesn't make sense? Ethan
Klein will never sue Destiny for calling him a
That's that's we're laughing at that. We're laughing at him being
a Ethan Klein was totally humiliated and he doesn't want to be
humiliated again. So he's terrified of the guy.
>> It's obviously true. >> I'm putting it on screen
because I think it should be addressed because it's a big bold
accusation that's very [__]
So he's saying like, "Hey, look, Destiny's calling you a Why
aren't you talking about this?" That was the intent. I don't
Again, he leaves it on the screen for a a long amount of time,
I believe. Um I don't know how long, but I I I think So Destiny
was calling you up. Everybody could tell that? Already? That's
the point. You left it on the screen for a long time. Okay. We
pointed it out and then he eventually explains, oh by the way,
I disavow. But that's the point. Like it's a claim And then we
pointed out and then he said I disavow. What doesn't make sense?
What is not making sense up until this point? What Destiny made
and he's asking why Ethan's not responding to it. That that's
that's what's happening there. He's saying in the stream that
he doesn't agree with it. In large It's okay. So I do want I
feel like this is him unironically doing the Hasan's bad thing.
Where like you have to say that for other people so they're not
freaking out. Right? Like Hasan's bad. Like Hasan is stupid and
he he really sucks.
But like this kind of isn't that bad.
He's going to explain his stupid joke that made no sense. And
that I totally agree with the logic of. I want to say I don't
agree because why would you? All right, I have to explain the
Destiny thing. I think that when people say that somebody's not
addressing Destiny or somebody's that There's a thing that happens
when Destiny enters any discourse where people's brains just
get pulled out of their head and it goes out the window. I don't
think this is an example of one of those times. I feel like you
kind of have to address the elephant in the room on this one.
It's a It's a quote from Destiny. And it's like this is how we
this is how we ruin iDubbbz and Anisa.
And um in response to a lot of this drama cuz obviously I made
a polarizing tweet about this. And then the response to this
is, Nick, you don't understand. When you say that you don't like
this lawsuit or you don't agree with this lawsuit, there's only
two things at play here. One, you're afraid you're going to get
sued. I'm not. And two, um you are just you're like you don't
understand the law. Canada doesn't have free speech. They're
But it's like you don't understand, Nick. This is a This is a
He's doing this because they're in Canada and there's no free
speech in Canada. I get that part. I get that it's an uphill
battle to win that argument in in America to go after Destiny
in in Florida man, Miami.
If I told you that I don't want to take place I I don't want
to fight somebody on equal terms, I'd rather go beat up a homeless
guy in the alley. Would you chad yes with me on that one? iDubbbz
and his wife are pathetic poor losers. They've lost Is okay.
So
should you not go after them cuz they're pathetic poor losers?
lost everything. Their chat is full of A-logs who hate them.
The other A-logs Uh-huh. are bored of their content. They're
not even watching anymore. This guy streamed on a channel with
millions of subscribers, okay? Streamed streamed on a channel
with millions of subscribers to like 200, 300 people. This guy's
lost everything. There's there's nothing to take from him. So,
no, I don't I don't find it fun to go, "Oh, he's in Canada. We
can him." >> But, like it's again, I'm sorry and I don't
mean to like I don't want to [__] on Casey Tronq
cuz I feel like she gets [__] on enough, okay? It's
just like punching down, it feels awkward, okay?
how does that not apply to CASEY TRONQ?
WHY ARE you pretending this is where the line is?
This isn't where the line is. This wasn't where the line was.
Dude, Brogan was like trying to fundraise for her rent and crying
about how hard streaming is and how she's not going to make it.
And you were gleeful.
YOU GUYS WERE GLEEFUL ABOUT THAT.
This isn't the line. YOU'RE TOTALLY PSYCHOTIC. YOU. He's already
There's nothing left to do. He's He's done. He's He's What are
you going to take his He's got his animals? ARE ARE YOU GOING
TO ARE YOU GOING TO ARE YOU GOING to make his wife grab THE SKIN
OFF HER ARMS AND PUT HER TATTOOS on your wall? LIKE WHAT ELSE
IS THERE TO TAKE from this guy? You understand what I'm saying?
It's like, YEAH, I DON'T THINK YOU CAN CHAD yes this. It looks
like you're beating a [__] into the ground. This
It looks like you're running a train on Ricky Berwick. Like what
the [__] is this? That's my take. But, let's hear
his let's hear his kind of discussion on it. Let's jump into
the the iDubbz finally apologizes video, which should give us
the context that we're looking for. Nick, I would take their
tattoos. Dude, their tattoos are worth negative equity. I wouldn't
do
>> Dude, hey, yeah, like they you threatening to take Casey's
house from her. I just That's what it was. It was the same thing.
Also, and >> Ethan's petting Nick, he's not going to stop.
All he will accomplish by going down this road further is just
>> I absolutely
and I, you know, got to be careful with the language. Ethan Klein
is petty. I'm sorry. That is not enough. That is not a That is
not a criticism.
Ethan Klein is petty.
Ethan Klein is evil. Ethan Klein is totally malicious. He's totally
vindictive. Petty is lightning what he does. He is not petty.
He is vindictive. He is malicious and vindictive and he wants
to hurt anybody who he who he even remotely thinks has ever hurt
him.
And he will by the way, if he does attribute some harm to you
that you like you've hurt him in some way, he will try to destroy
you. It will not be commensurate, will not be like reciprocal
harm. It will be I'm going to do everything I can to kill you
in a metaphorical financial sense. It's that's it's not just
pettiness. That's not just being petty. Being petty is like
you [__] talk somebody because they were mean to
you once. Being petty is way way different a way way lighter
charge than what Ethan Klein actually does. Come on, man. Public
support. >> I don't think it's a drama community thing.
I think and this is controversial, Ethan has done things that
have pulled good grace in from sectors of the internet that otherwise
would not have liked the things that he was doing or or things
that he said or and that happened probably over the course of
like two or three years. I think when you just start suing everybody
who talked [__] about you you kind of like that's
yeah, I didn't like the Noah Samson lawsuit. >> What did
he do about the Noah Samson
Was he What was the commentary in the Noah Samson lawsuit? >> I
apologize to my audience. I said it would never happen. My position
on the Noah Samson lawsuit was I think this guy just defames
people constantly. You can find out on Rob's Media's video about
what a sneaky piece of [__] this guy is. So, the
fact that he's getting like shell-shocked right now that a lawsuit
is coming his way and he's potentially leaving the country or
something, I thought it was really funny. I don't necessarily
think it was worth suing him. And I'm waiting to hear what the
justification was today, but I was kind >> I don't necessarily
think it was worth suing him. I don't necessarily think it was
worth suing him.
I'm totally psyched he's getting sued. I don't know if it would
necessarily want to sue him. Where's the Ethan, you're acting
like a piece of [__] >> I mean that he was
just living scared for an entire calendar year. That was particularly
funny to me. Because he deserves it. He's like a little sneaky
piece of [__] and he deserves to be looking over
his shoulder because honestly, he was running a little Hey, he's
malicious. That's the issue. It's actually the issue about it.
he's malicious and he showcased that he's malicious multiple
times already. >> But you're not Why is he talking around
it, right? Do you see how weaselly this
He's malicious. He's malicious. Was he malicious here? I think
this is Dude, now I'm remembering I covered this cuz this is
the same thing I said. I remember covering it before. Is he malicious
here?
When he's defaming Ethan, so-called, when he's engaging in so-called
defamation against Ethan Klein. No, obviously not. This is This
is an abhorrent sweep. My god. Okay, hold on. >> Someone
can like Ethan but also call him out for getting too petty. >> That's
too petty. This is too petty. >> to the Strait of Hormuz.
>> I don't even know what that is. >> silly joke
that I my children. By the way, Carolyn Kwan, do you have a problem
with that? That your bestie Anisa >> I I again I just think
it's comical. Idubbbz shows a screenshot of somebody >> He's
petty. Petty. He's like petty. He's like petty, man. Come on,
he's like >> just like got him. >> I I I'm petty.
>> He's silly joke that I my children. >> Is it too
petty? Yes. >> By the way, Carolyn Kwan, do you have a
problem with that?
That your bestie Anisa
says I my children. >> The Oreo commentator of the year,
the best commentator of the year. >> You even suing >> Did
Anisa say he his children?
Where's Where's Anisa saying that Ethan his kids?
Cuz that clip would be funny. >> For something that caused
him no damages and was clearly not meant to be taken as factual
uh would be creating this.
I yeah again I just I don't That's That's what I see here. I
don't >> degenerate loser
>> Probably not. >> And and people are like, "Oh,
Nick, it's about the Nick, you're just mad about the precedent.
You're scared about drama channels." Dude, the precedent is gone.
It's been set. Precedent's here. Everyone has to just kind of
like do the best they can to not make comments about Ethan his
[__] the kids or a comparable comment about other
people. I'm sure most people will be fine, right? I just don't
I just disagree with that, you
>> I think I would never speculate, okay? I would never
I would never even speculate on it. But there are two disparate
facts that exist in parallel.
Okay? One fact is that Destiny accused Ethan Klein of being a
his children. And the other disparate fact that is totally disconnected
is that truth is an absolute defense against defamation. >> And
by the way, pay Danny patrons, they're dropping.
Okay, my Danny pay my Danny's patrons on uh the up. We be farting,
stinking up that diner, okay?
>> Ooh, dude, I know every time Dude, we we must have watched
this. It's It's like my brain tries to forget watching Ethan
Klein segments, so I just I forget that he exists. I It's so
rough to listen to, dude. >> Um, it was kind of >> I'm
I'm listening I'm going to hear Ethan out as I have done in every
other >> kind of like a a way for me to like get involved
in the in the slop that I >> Why is Nick pretending that
he hasn't already given his opinion on all of this? I'm going
to hear Ethan out. You already heard him out. You already don't
You already disagree with him. >> To be honest, I don't
like being >> You said as much on Twitter. >> kind
of all I wanted to say with the uh with the content calm. >> Is
that right? >> That's usually my strategy is like, this
is my opinion, take it or leave it.
>> Cuz you spent months and months
directly interfacing
and shouting out. >> Again, I think the segment goes this
goes ham. Ethan responding to iDubbbz. Yeah, oh, what happened
months ago? Hmm, back when you had more viewers, back when you
were trying to rebuild your stream, you were talking [__]
about me all the time to pay the bills.
It just feels worthless knowing the end of this that iDubbbz
only did this because he got a letter in the mail. It feels worthless.
This feels like the triumphant victory where you're like, I didn't
do anything and THEY THAT DUDE, THAT'S WHAT NO Ian April was.
No Ian April was the triumphant victory that we didn't do f-
anything and their lives got worse. And now I just found out
that this guy put a letter in his door.
Doesn't that feel cheap to you?
>> The Oreo commentator of the year, the >> not feel
cheap to anybody?
>> a vile, disgusting, degenerate snark.
What do you mean it feels
Dude, I Okay. >> all the same people on Twitter. Now >> He
didn't want to win this way. It's just so
>> only to change her heart. Hmm, I wonder if there's another
reason. >> do a a follow-up video. >> literally did
nothing to them. You know, Ian and April was a total sham. >> But
generally I I want to move on, live my life. >> That's
so >> Thank you. He just started insulting me viciously
on Twitter. >> So, I have the scores to >> logical
take is Ian is not allowed to use Ethan to make content in any
If he does, Ethan will try to stop him. It's personal, but it
isn't about gain. >> I think that sucks. I
Why would anybody approve of that? Why would anybody approve
of that ever? That's totally psychotic.
This person just donated. How much did that person just donate?
$20 to go
Uh actually, E- Ethan just gets to keep his knee on iDubbbz's
neck for the rest of history.
Yeah. Yeah, just let let let Ethan keep his neck his knee on
iDubbbz's neck. That's that's okay, and that's good.
It isn't about gain. It's personal, but it isn't about gain.
How would that make it okay? >> allowed to use Ethan to
make content in any capacity.
If he does, Ethan will try to stop him. It's personal, but it
isn't about gain. >> I think that sucks. I think that sucks.
>> Goom on. I have I've been indulging
>> Wait, I was the one who made Ian's life worse. Wait.
Nick, dude. Complete Israeli victory. Lex Luthor, total victory.
Let's go.
Nick is on the side of Israel. Let's go,
>> And the the dark side a little too much. Is that right?
I have my own principles, my own values, and I'm like >> I
think people got com- like comfortable too comfortable with the
fact that people have said horrific [__] about
And he's fighting and he's been fighting back and fighting the
good fight.
At some point
war is over. At some point war is over. >> At some point
guys, you have to stop using my really bad justification cuz
actually if you use all of the principles I gave you before,
if you if you apply the standard I did before, I'm going to look
really bad and if I keep consistent on this, I'm going to get
by a bunch of people who made a video about me.
This Kilo guy made a video about me and I I can't be like this
anymore. I can't do it anymore.
Dude, like it's just the Kilo video. It's the only thing that
changed. That's it. That's it. Nick doesn't even have to watch
the Kilo video if he's going to switch up this much. Let's go.
>> But at some point people should be allowed to criticize
Ethan without getting a >> Just kidding. You do have to
watch the Kilo video. I mean if you want if you want absolution,
you got to watch the Kilo video. >> letter under their
door, right? >> It allowed me to
to to roll >> At some point scorched earth has to end.
>> around in the pig [__] a little bit
>> Did this guy just say at some point scorched earth has
to end? Does he know when scorched earth ends? Does he know what
scorched earth means? Do you have any idea what you just said?
It's like at some point the at some point total war ends. Yeah,
do you know what that point is, Nick? When the other guy is in
a ditch. That's when it ends. That's when scorched earth ends.
>> more and I you know, there's aspects of that that I
like, but it's not [snorts] really like it doesn't super align
with my principles.
I think one of the things that >> He's too principled guys
to joke about a man and his children. He's only now had a change
of I've only realized now guys, that was wrong. Huh. You know,
I watch a lot of >> even say that? He hasn't said that.
>> He he does. >> He implied he his kids.
I mean, implying he his children isn't criticism. He has principles.
He has
Look at the stakes and what Ethan has to lose versus what Ethan
is Ethan is trying to gain. Ethan lets most people talk [__]
about him, including the crew, to his face.
So much sweeping, man. And they're all going to be the biggest
donors who are the sweepers, right? Again.
>> I say I don't agree with what's being said in this um
comment here.
Uh but I I'm putting it on screen >> He's just going to
keep pulling it back
>> I think it should be addressed because it's a big >> Dude,
it's Destiny making an allegation and he's suing iDubbbz for
it. >> kept on squealing. [laughter] >> Stupid. I'm
That's so
>> CPS came to his home, interviewed his kids. They call
them PT on the daily. Pedo troll on the daily. This ultimately
stopped being a joke once it involved his kids. They went too
far and he's in the right to shut them up. This is what you created,
Nick.
Nick, this is who you This is the community you built.
It's so funny watching this guy get by the by the sword he forged.
It's so funny, man. Why Why won't you guys just listen to me?
Like
You can't just say CPS and skulls every single time. You can't
do it for
Destiny dude, I
>> Destiny can just be like, yeah, dude, uh you your kids
and then iDubbbz is just
puts it on the screen, sued. I I don't >> context that
makes this all make sense and I'm going to give it to you guys
after the clip. So stand back and stand And surprises throughout.
So no skipping.
>> We don't know if he threatened Destiny,
He might have He might have threatened Destiny. He might have
threatened Destiny, actually. Guys, he could have totally threatened
Destiny.
Yeah. Destiny got a legal threat that he didn't immediately show
up to his stream with and act like a victim with. Yeah, definitely.
That sounds reasonable. Totally. Totally. Totally. Well, actually,
hold on. That might be reasonable, but not this one. This one
he would have showed up with. If he had another like s- case
that was getting like threatened against him, like basically
he leaked somebody's or he did something like that, he would
absolutely not leak that cuz he does not want any more of that
going public. He doesn't want anybody to know about anything
like that. But for this, oh yeah, he'd complain about this. 100%.
>> Wasn't the prevailing theory at the time that iDubbz
was testing it as a watermark to try to stop Ethan from clipping
him? He had it on for an entire day, but immediately dropped
it when Ethan called him out the next day. >> Wait, really?
>> He He had it on the screen and then Ethan called him
out and then he stopped using it? Fun- I didn't I didn't even
remember that, but that's a good point. >> I'm I We know
the reason that I, you know, uh showed you guys the the comments.
>> Well, that would be a That would be an excellent use
of your platform. >> about Ethan and his kids.
>> it's like Destiny's a He's a piece of >> What
is he implying? It's exactly what he says here in this clip.
He's implying >> Play it again, play it again. >> Is
he going to play it again? >> He's busy addressing all
of the um like the >> That's a lot, man. >> But he
called out Destiny on that stream and then nothing, radio silence,
no other Destiny related media to the point where now where Destiny
makes a like a comment in his offline chat, which I think is
is spiteful,
um saying that daily reminder Ethan from h3 is likely a We're
now watching him threaten iDubbz with a lawsuit for showing it.
That's where we're at. Yeah. So, again, in a way, he kind of
argues Ian's point a little bit. It As as it is, >> clearly
he has bad [snorts] intentions, but he's going easy on this guy.
>> I don't think we have enough information on whether
he's threatened Destiny or not. Yeah, and you know what? If that's
the case, good. Good. If he If he's If he's done that, all right,
that's absolutely important for the discussion,
but that's not information that's available to us, and that would
be kind of something important to note. >> He [__]
on you more than anybody of all of them. And I'm suing Noah Samson,
by the way, as well. >> Yeah, I think that you shouldn't
have. I think that that you were like on the last possible day,
and you had like I I think you should have just let it pass.
I think you should have let it pass.
No, you
>> What do we say? What kind of person wouldn't let it
pass, Nick? Can we do a little a little like, you know, second-order
analysis here? Can we get past that like initial shallow layer
of "Oh, you shouldn't have done that." Well, if somebody consistently
does things that they shouldn't do, because those actions in
in individual senses could be defensible, but in aggregate make
you seem a certain way, what is the way they seem? If you act
in a way that is like bad, then you're like at your core kind
of bad. Like, you're not a good person. Like Jesus Christ, man.
>> Well, you platformed it because you're a cowardly loser.
And and you thought it was cute. I don't I would never say
if you think that a person who's been beaten to the point where
they have like 100 viewers, where they're all half their audience,
three-quarters of their audience hates them, >> their main
channel is dead, they have no online influence, um the words
that they say are only being seen basically by people who hate
them, who circulate the clips to [__] on them, um
who are like living in a basement right now, if you think that
we should take more from those people who basically already have
nothing,
then why stop there? Like, what is it What is an act that would
be too far? Like, at At point, like, why wouldn't you just
them? Wouldn't that be hilarious? No, I
I wonder. I'm trying to think like I'm trying to think I think
is Ethan at the capacity for that?
I don't think so. But I just don't get where like this is significantly
different from the Casey Tron thing other than that.
Uh what would it be with Casey Tron? What's the difference?
I can't this the Casey Tron thing is the same except they go
well she called CPS.
She was part of that group. I don't think I I don't know like
what what The legal merit? Wait.
It maybe it it like it could be meritorious in Canada to sue
items on
It could be. I'd say the legal case against Casey Tron is like
open and shut. So that's different maybe. Okay, yeah. Yeah yeah
yeah okay maybe there's a a stronger case there. Morally I think
it's the same. I think it's the exact same. But sure that there's
a lot of legal merit for the Casey case. What act is too far
where it starts to become [__] up for you? Like where
is your line? Where is your line where it would start to become
[__] up?
Like sue them into poverty? They're already there.
That about like that's just that's something like okay bro.
You've clearly lost it and everybody said it at the time everybody
talked about it. All of a sudden now he's got to change of heart.
Okay. >> Many others right? And that that was my reason.
He was on opioids.
>> Thank you for showing it. >> I think the platforming
the message and them knowing Ethan was when the straw broke the
camel's back. I still think it's dumb to sue them for a ham sandwich.
Wow. >> But I was like >> It's not like totally totally
disgusting wretched behavior. It's just like bad. >> You
know after >> Oh sorry it's dumb. It's dumb. I they're
not even going to go to bad. It's just >> Reflecting a
little bit more I'm like uh I do not want to roll around this
big >> It's not within my principles
to put that >> guy's going to be a Uber driver in a >> No,
I am not. >> I'm sorry to Ethan and Ethan's family
>> you could you could choking on the ash. The of scorched
lagoon. You could he just doesn't want to say it so bad.
So sorry. >> I don't know why he didn't just say that Ethan
like sent us a cease and desist. >> Ethan I'm sorry. >> I'm
so sorry. >> to Ethan and >> Cuz it would have been
way It would have been honestly just like a viral clip. It already
went kind of viral, but it would have been a viral clip everywhere
if he said it. >> Ethan's family for uh putting that nasty
Destiny comment out felt like it was an okay thing to do. >> And
by the way, [clears throat] I have no issue with him saying [__]
you or any of the other [__] the normal [__]
on the >> you based on the point I was making, but
>> I don't think H3 has even interacted with Dusty. I have
been over to his house multiple times. Oh yeah, this whole like
oh this is close personal friend. That's what explains it. He's
like mad cuz this feels like a betrayal.
Yeah, huh. >> Yeah, you're yeah, like literally
I don't care. >> None of the None of the defenses are ever
This is actually good conduct.
Right? It's just like it's all just excuses for totally despicable
behavior. >> dumb ass >> Well, the question you're
asked >> justifications for totally despicable >> Give me
which is really stupid is would you be okay with the same people
who called CPS on your kids calling you a pedo? What would you
do? I probably wouldn't sue them. Especially if they said it
to three
Like it's the other person's donation again. It's like oh it
was on the screen the whole day. What like five people saw it?
Six? Six people? Six Six noble Ian supporters that already read
it on on r/h3snark?
>> Gross shouldn't be spread like that. >> You don't
[snorts] think that people say crazy [__] about me
every single day? >> It's hard, man. >> You [__]
spread it for like months, bro. It was your watermark on your
whole episode. Like you I mean
You know? >> It's hard because they catch [__]
all the time and it's like, "How do I engage?"
Well, I have to have to be Wow, these guys talk [__]
all the time. Gee, me, the content cop guy, I don't know how
to deal with that. >> This is the internet? No, this is
not the internet. This is litigation,
>> which is gay.
>> I'm going to say he mo >> In this context, yeah,
I think this is like there's there's just there's no actual damage.
This guy's done no
>> Less his children.
>> If it was the internet, there'd be a back and forth.
This guy doesn't have the He doesn't have the legs to handle
the back. >> Is that what we need? >> Hold on. >> Well,
I have to have to be Wow, these guys talk [__] all
the time. Gee, me, the content cop guy, I don't know how to deal
with that. >> This is the internet? No, this is not the
internet. This is litigation,
which is gay.
>> I'm going to say he mo >> And what is If it's
gay, then I've got some bad news for you, Nick.
James Charles, Adam McIntyre,
these are not the gayest uh in the commentary space, okay? It's
not the gayest on the internet. Ethan Klein, Ethan Klein is a
power bottom right now, okay?
Nobody operate like this guy does. Why did this guy call out
any other dude?
Why Why would he not watch the killer video? I Now I feel like
he might not have watched the killer video. He might have only
seen small parts of it or something. You have defended every
SINGLE TIME. YOU BASICALLY DEFENDED. YOU justified suing Noah
Samsen. Even though you say you disagreed with suing Noah Samsen
for the reasons Ethan did, you basically justified to kick off
your
>> In this context, yeah, I think this is like there's
there's just there's no actual damage. This guy's done no
>> Less his children.
>> If it was the internet, there'd be a back and forth.
This guy doesn't have the He doesn't have the legs to handle
the back.
>> Epic epic, bro.
>> He nasty back. It's tough. It's tough. [snorts] From
what I've seen, it seems like their podcast has slowed down with
specific harassment,
publicized
intentional harassment against Anisa and >> Dude, one point
they declared the CPS Bro, we have talked ad nauseam. They got
You got like 60 videos to click on my channel where iDubbz CPS
call probably pops up on Filmon. I know better than anyone. I
agree with you. >> I'm back, [__] It's not
harassment. >> Is real life damage?
No, there's not. There is no real life damage from this. There
is none. >> By the way, literally responding to you.
Honestly, I would love to talk about you more, but I see your
career dwindling
like a It's like spring but
Okay, no damage, no damage. >> But the water never came.
It's a bad harvest this year, Paul.
It's like the the greens there your your career is dwindling.
>> It's like Oh, man. I I don't understand people like
this. It just feels psychotic. Like
I get people when when we I had like the clash when I first started
streaming with Tom Follery. And like that was really funny and
it was heated and it was back and forth. But once Tom's channel
was like withering away, I didn't show up every day to check
in and see like how badly he was doing or
That would be psychotic.
Like realistically, there's a a lot of this stuff is just like
on the internet. I'm not going to look at people's views and
just like
reveling in how bad it gets, right? I just it's it's kind of
gross. It's just obscene. >> Anisa
had to announce that she's quitting streaming after grand entrance
because you couldn't even crack a hundred live.
And now yours is going down. You're at 400, bro.
>> I agree. These are all points I agree on. Yes.
>> Oh, we got a we got a rough harvest this
And when I talk [__] on you, it's just like sprinkling
a little water on your It's not even worth
It isn't He's right. HE'S RIGHT. IT'S NOT WORTH IT. IT'S NOT
EVEN WORTH TALKING ABOUT THEM. >> worth it. That's how
irrelevant you've >> Dude, I'm I'm really just here for
>> of my favorite things to [__] on you >> I'm
really just here for It's too bad. I'm watching this at the very
end of the stream, so I feel like I'm not quite as engaged as
I was earlier with some of the politics stuff, okay? Not quite
as engaged. What can you do?
But oh, and valuable foul, what's up? Both both in the Twitch
chat and the Kick chat.
I I'm excited for the part where he gets to do Dan stuff, and
we can see Dan like cook with this guy. Well, sorry, cook with
Ethan, and all of that. I'm very excited for that. I wonder how
long it's going to take us to get there. Oh, I don't have scan.
Well, whatever. Keep >> I like watching it. >> Keep
going.
I'm appreciate giving the opportunity to do it. >> Yeah,
dude. I can't smack it. >> If Ethan had sued Pestily first
and then sued iDubbz, I don't think I'd see this as such a lame
course of action. >> Your career is falling. That's why
I'm going to take I'm going to file a
>> And give you a huge win. It's a morale booster for the
for the four remaining iDubbz fans.
But it's just >> That's all this is. This is giving This
isn't It's an excuse for everyone to rally behind this loser.
>> It's not my It's not my prerogative anymore because
at this point it just >> Like would you consider opioids?
>> The wheat ain't coming in this year, boss. I don't know
what we're going to
That's you, bro. You're like Grapes of Wrath, broke ass. >> Which
one is he? >> The one that breastfeeds the baby >> at
the end.
He's that one. >> Yeah, like I'm reading this right now.
Actually, calling someone a dick is considered defamation. Really?
Wow, dude. I didn't even pass the bar. Are you sure about that?
But the reality of the situation is if I if I go into the forest
and I scream that a tree and no one is around to hear me, does
it make a sound? Like is the tree is the tree going to sue me?
>> You brought. >> I'm sorry every Again, I'm just
going to ask how does that not apply to Casey Tron?
If if somebody violates your intellectual property in a forest
and nobody's there to see it, do they really violate your intellectual
property? >> I'm burning >> Dude, if I if a homeless
walks up to you in Penn Station calling you a and screaming Bible
verses at you, would you be like, "Yo, this guy, I need to I
need to contact my lawyer stat. Let me get Ron Varnassi on the
phone. We're going to [__] up this with this drunk
homeless dude on the subway." That's what I think when I look
at Ian. I see like a a drunk Bible preacher walking around Penn
Station. That's what I think of him. It just this just is like
that's if that's my that's my mental ca- >> Little Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Little
Was that a little slip right there? >> on the subway."
That's what I think when I look at Ian. I see like a a drunk
Bible preacher >> I thought he might have said Ethan >> Oh,
no. >> walking around Penn Station. That's what I think
of him. It just this just is like that's if that's my that's
my mental capacity on iDubbbz. He's like a drunk Penn Station
>> oranges on the side of the road and your ass is walking
home in the Dust Bowl. >> Sue the homeless initiative was
a finished [__] I could get behind. >> Clips
of wrath reference >> Yeah, shout out to Ryan back. >> Thank
you for the $5, my man. >> Um great American novel. >> One
of the great American novels. >> No, oh yeah, so >> Yeah,
hold on, hold on. Look at how stupid these people are, man.
If someone punches you and nobody's recording, did it really
happen? The tree allegory doesn't isn't meant to say if you can't
hear it, it doesn't matter.
The tree allegory is saying that like there wasn't harm here.
You're saying there was harm. There is no harm here. >> Let
me tell you a little story. The second >> All right, so
this is that >> Stop talking about us. happen to coincide
when I took into my um
some fine Canadian lawyers. >> Again, that just kind of
sucks. That doesn't seem like a really awesome thing that's happened.
It's like as soon as he stopped talking about us, I thought he
just took a hit took an initiative and he got shut down to the
point where it wasn't worth it anymore. Now it's like no, he
got a letter under his door. Keep it all things >> started
insulting me viciously on >> Thank you. >> That's
right. Um [snorts] lawyers who specialize in defamation and >> How
does that suck? I I don't know like I There's probably no way
that we can meet him this one if you don't think that that sucks.
I've gone through it already. I'm not going to re-litigate the
entire thing. But yeah, when you're looking at No Ian and April
and you're seeing his numbers go down, he's not talking about
anything, he looks just diminished or whatever, and his wife
quit streaming, and we find out oh, it has nothing to do with
the fact that he was they were getting starved out. It's because
they literally just can't talk about drama anymore because Ian
threatened to sue because Ethan threatened to sue them. That
diminishes the accomplishment. It means No Ian and April literally
meant nothing. It was just because that Ian Ethan threatened
to sue him over the screenshot on the
>> By the way, Nick thinks that Nick basically
Here's the real Here's the real analysis here. Nick is like,
I look like a total [__] now.
I was like crowing about how I was destroying their channel by
I Oh, they relied on me. They relied on me completely for any
viewership. And he's crowing about it, and then he finds out
that his boss, the guy he sweeps for, is
threatening to sue, and they can no longer do content effectively.
So, all of your crowing was totally stupid. You
Yeah, that's what it is. He He just looks like a now. That's
what he's actually upset about, right? >> diminished or
whatever, and his wife quit streaming, and we find out oh, it
has nothing to do with the fact that he was they were getting
starved out. It's because they literally just can't talk about
drama anymore because Ian threatened to sue because Ethan threatened
to sue them. That diminishes >> He really wasn't lying
when he made it sound like he thinks drama's about being on the
winning side. Yeah, he always picks the right side, guys. This
is um Dude, there's a
>> There's a fantasy character who's like this. Very funny,
right?
Like basically, well,
I'm not going to go into it. I would take too long to explain
the character to you guys. >> accomplishment. It means
No Ian and April literally meant nothing. It was just because
that Ian Ethan threatened to sue him over the screenshot on the
>> By the way, [laughter] I really don't think that's okay.
thing to put out. Some fine Canadian um defamation lawyers that
sent a letter to
and [snorts] uh Ian demanding
>> a retraction and a
>> Ethan's audience has become too snarky for me. Ethan's
audience has become too snarky for me. These people These people
don't think they're snarkers. They don't think they're snarkers.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. >> I'm going with slaying. Like
Smaug. One There was only one scale >> So, a lot of people
point out that uh >> I say something to you, Nick. >> Tywin
Lannister taught you a pen was mightier than a sword, okay? And
in the world of Westeros, disarming an entire military with a
single letter and sending something into disarray seems pretty
badass.
In a YouTube slap fight where people are constantly [__]
on each other back and forth, it's just too petty for me. That's
you just lose me on that. The pen being mightier than the sword
here just kind of
>> And it was the flight of a >> It's Dude, this
is your job. You're just talking [__] with somebody.
And basically, it's like
Dude, you you have like uh yeah yeah yeah, some job. You get
beat in your job. It's like some I don't know. You're like a
boxer or something. You lose. And you like go and grab a gun
and shoot the guy.
It's like, "Okay. You always could have done that. That doesn't
make you like a better boxer. It kind of just makes you look
like a bitch."
what are we even doing here, man? >> It's probably the
same Game of Thrones. Yeah, that's why I'm cringing. >> It's
possible. That's right.
It's not because they're principled. It's not because he's above
it. In fact, they're hurting bad. >> Fidias probably thought,
"I need to make this video so Ethan doesn't sue us because I'll
give him what he wants right out of the way." bros. And that's
the whole video. His whole video is whole apologies. It's just
like That's how I perceive it. It's like if I just make this
video ahead of time, Ethan will leave us alone.
Which might work, might not. >> Isn't that video explicitly
in reaction to the lawsuit?
>> In 10 years, when Teddy connects the very public dots
from all the revolting things said about him and his family.
>> Okay, Ethan needs to do >> Tell your audience
that they have right now. They are hysterical. They are histrionic.
They're losing their minds.
Actually, it's somewhat justified for them to sue all these people
because Teddy might have trauma 10 years from
Even though I don't even know how much he talked to anybody from
ZPS.
Do a trial by combat.
Thank you.
I just saw Keemstar's tweet on Nicholas
Just said yes, thank you.
Ethan needs to do a trial by combat.
Thank you.
Oh, no. He just did another Game Thrones reference instead of
responding to that comment. Cuz it was totally insane and histrionic.
All right, cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Yes, trial by combat.
That's what needs to happen.
>> Let's go.
He's out here now bragging about silencing an internet critic
with a lawsuit. You have a much bigger platform. Use it for sake's.
This is lame as
Call him what he is, you
Yes, trial by combat. That's what needs to happen.
It's not even just a critic. Did he not understand that they're
saying like Nicholas Deorio, you're lame
It's not even like
The problem Dude, the problem is he's talking like I slayed the
dragon. No, you stepped on an ant.
>> No. No. No. No. Oh, he didn't Did he not comprehend
what that donation was?
They're saying Nicholas, stand with a spine and say this is bad
and I don't want to be associated with somebody who does [__]
like this. That's the minimum. That's the bare minimum.
Cuz you slayed an ant.
Look at him. Falling off so hard. It's crazy how hard he's falling
off. It was literally the day he stopped talking about it, right?
He doesn't talk about the snark anymore. He doesn't talk about
me anymore. You'd rather Ethan fight Ian than than sue him? >> Yeah.
Yeah, actually, yeah. >> And um Derek, by the >> not
But again, it's not even worth fighting. I don't know if you
mean with fists or swords or just general pushback. Yes, I would
rather general pushback, too. Yeah. But there's no reason to.
I don't see like he's >> It's really unfortunate This is
the ultimate irony, and I love this. America, love America.
If you lived in California, I wouldn't even bother threatening
to sue him. >> Because Okay, this is All right, this is
the part >> Nicholas the goat, thank you for the >> that
pisses me off. This is the part that pisses me off. So, let's
stand back, stand by. Listen to this. >> California, I
wouldn't even bother threatening to sue him. Because of Because
of In our great state, we have anti-SLAPP laws that make it extraordinarily
difficult to sue um public figures for defamation. And we have
this extreme appreciation for for free speech in the First Amendment.
Now, let me tell you something. Ian
this part, I don't know how he's triumphantly pushing this. Hey,
in California, I couldn't file this cuz it would get slapped
down, but because you fled to Canada, I can just [__]
you. And that's And then that's that's to booming applause? Like,
hey, because of this like legal loophole, you're
>> Sorry, you made a legal loophole because
because there are different or no protections to stop me from
doing vexatious litigation, I'm going to try to kill you. I'm
going to try to sue you
California, it's And then by the way, he says it makes the case
tougher, but it doesn't make the case tougher. Anti-SLAPP laws,
they don't make the case tougher. They make it so that you can't
vexatiously sue somebody. You can't pursue vexatious litigation
against a critic with anti-SLAPP laws because it will get slapped
down, even though that's not what SLAPP means, but it'll get
slapped down.
that's just That's that's just too petty for me. I don't know.
If you're like, "Hey, this isn't a strong case where I live,
but due to technicality, I can [__] you in Canada."
I don't Okay, cool. >> If you want to engage in this, uh-oh.
Just because you can legally sue somebody doesn't make it morally
right. Uh-oh, Nicholas.
You don't want to Oh, no. You don't want to engage in that. You
don't want to start You don't want to start entertaining that
argument. That would look real bad, wouldn't it? If you started
engaging with the argument of well, just cuz you can sue somebody
doesn't mean you should or that it's
If you start entertaining those thoughts, oh boy, Ethan's going
to seem a little different in retrospect. Uh-oh. >> from
America, >> Stop. I don't know why we make fun of legal
mindset for going to going to >> But now that you're in
Canada,
I found me a Canadian lawyer who's pretty gung-ho about suing
you. >> That's America. >> And I might just do that.
And you know, he's grow
just take the win. I I Dude, they're just handing you win after
win after win and you're like handing it back. It's like, no,
dude, send it back. >> Why would you still sue him after
he publicly just made that statement? Why would you just Why
are we Why are we leaving the door open to file the lawsuit?
Why? >> Well, he's He's apologized. >> Yeah, but
the damage is done. >> So, his apology was not >> Yeah,
I agree. He apologized, but >> See people They're taking
this to mean >> THE DAMN WHAT DAMAGE? WHAT DAMAGE WAS >> That
you threatened them and that in response, he's apologizing. No,
he's >> We're in talks. >> Oh, okay. >> They're
desperate to prevent litigation. >> Got you. >> And
they've preemptively apologized out >> This is funny because
he backstabbed him
Yes, I agree with you. All iDubbbz bad.
And then Ethan went on the one of the
iDubbbz assassinat- not cannot character
Ethan like assassinated that guy in a in in in the in like in
the in the
sense, right? He went out there and mauled him for like a year
and then iDubbbz had nothing left. The repercussions of that
has already been felt.
No. Like he's felt it. He lost. He's
>> um patheticness. But you know, in my opinion, because
we there's no
You just want to go, "I'm so sorry.
Please, my principles." >> be sorry. Think >> Exact-
Exactly.
Thank you, Christopher.
>> Christian. Not Christopher. I'm close. >> OH,
GOOD FOR YOU.
>> SO, um
>> I Look, Nick, I
I know you're saying this is too petty, but I'm not calling it
that. This is pretty malicious. The slap suit clip is pretty
bad. I got Yeah, I just think it's crazy to be like, "Listen,
I'm only doing this because legally I could [__]
you in Canada." >> And Mike, yeah. >> And that also
people were using that as a defense. I go to my replies, I'll
probably find it. We're like, "The reason why they're not doing
it in the US is cuz the statute is significantly harder to prove
against Destiny. That's why he wouldn't sue him there." And it's
then maybe he shouldn't. >> I wouldn't you just judge it
on other factors? Like not not purely on how hard it is to prosecute
or or to actually sue somebody for it? You just Like, why is
he trying to find He's trying to find any standard for this behavior
that isn't one he claims that isn't based on his principles?
>> I think for one, our laws are good. I think [laughter]
if if our laws would be a would be too difficult for this lawsuit
to make it past, then maybe he shouldn't do it. >> So,
the defamation's already happened. We sent him a letter saying
like, "Hey, you got to stop cuz your the damages are just melting
up." And they desperately stopped, right? >> I appreciate
the people who are like, "Yeah, malice, sure. Petty, sure. Uh
no damages, but I don't care." I I appreciate the honesty from
those >> And they got a lawyer. And now [snorts] we're
just talking I don't want to give away the details of our settlement
because I'm I am I'm way above that.
Right, Dan?
>> You're above giving details of the >> the Canadian
legal system with >> Any comment? Any comment on that?
That pause there? >> utmost care and respect.
No, you're not supposed to share any details as well. >> I
would never I would never The Crown would never >> You
usually share everything, so that doesn't sound right at all.
>> uh the Crown. >> Okay. So, it sounds like because
you're not allowed to. >> Not allowed to is one thing,
but I >> By that logic, no one should ever exercise international
law cuz laws are different in every country. Well, I think that
personally, if you file a defamation lawsuit like DarkViper was
going to do in Europe where >> I think if you're filing
defamation
to silence people from talking about you, silence critics who
aren't really doing like something that is defamatory, they're
not lying about you, they just don't like you, right? It's super
easy. Like iDubbbz was not lying about him. iDubbbz doesn't like
him. And by far, Ethan has directed more harassment, more hate,
more harm to iDubbbz than vice versa. It's not even close. The
idea that iDubbbz has somehow done more harm to Ethan than vice
versa is crazy.
I don't even know where you start where you begin to or make
that argument. It's confusing to me.
So, the idea that Ethan has something that he needs to pay iDubbbz
back for is >> I just respect the crown. >> Okay,
got it. >> But, I will say that >> I think I'm going
to do it, right? >> No! No! No! >> Because the damages,
right? To my reputation
are
>> are terrible. I feel terribly damaged.
>> HE'S NOT DUDE!
HE'S NOT EVEN SELLING IT! >> THERE'S ACTUALLY such a crazy
funny thing about the Canadian thing, too, because he moved to
Canada. I learned you can't even crowd fund >> Woah! Woah!
>> in Canada. >> I can really [__] with
them. I There's such a crazy awesome thing. I just learned that
I can actually destroy their personal finances and nobody can
help them. You can't even crowd fund in
>> And you can't you
>> So, I I'm not sure the exact law about if he did >> This
is what I'm trying to You're literally By the way, I made this
I made this comparison maybe 3 weeks ago and people in my Discord
lost their minds.
But, Ethan Klein is literally somebody who tortures small animals.
Like there are there are major
empathy deficits here that that aren't explained by the harm
done to him by not even the CPS call, none of it. It's just there's
it's just like ego. It's just narcissism fueling him entirely.
I say, it's just this is too petty for me. Maybe I should have
played the whole clip before I started fighting the chatters
about it. This is just this is too much, dude.
>> This guy is now apologized to you
and defaced himself. Funny, cool, whatever. And and we're still
going to we're still like off the idea of going through with
it. >> have to basically ID and verify the identity of
every single person that gives money. >> Oh, okay. >> So,
it's like basically virtually impossible it would be to, you
know, do something like that on GoFundMe.
So, he they're not even capable of crowdfunding for this. The
fact that he they moved to the camera >> they have to do
that? iDubbbz is a really successful YouTuber. >> You're
right. >> a lot of money, right? >> Yes, you're right.
I I assume a lot of people would want to support them, that's
all. >> In fact, I didn't I hear that uh
that they never have to work another day in their life?
You're actually a pretty funny guy. >> The damage to my
reputation with the
>> Yeah, I dude, I don't know. It's It's like hey, if you
look at this, what you're seeing is hey, you [__]
up, you said the wrong thing in a place where you can't say the
thing, and I'm glad that you weren't here, so now I can release
the the kraken and it'll hunt you down and sink your ship. >> Let's
give it up for the man.
>> True, right.
So, [snorts] um should be Yeah, no problem. Should be no problem
for them. But um at at at any rate uh this is about Look, this
is about protecting my family, my reputation, you know? And the
fact that he moved to Canada >> Again, I don't think that
it is, and I've I've said it repeatedly. I do think that like
the other lawsuits are petty as well, right? Like he's doing
petty things. He's going after people who have said like horrible
things about him, and I think the majority of you guys probably
agree with that.
Including iDubbbz. iDubbbz has also said like horrible things
about him.
I just this is this is too much for me.
>> What has iDubbz said truly like reprehensible [__]
about him? >> Like this is beating a homeless man on the
side of the road. That's what this feels like. >> Nicholas Deorio
streamed about this last night and after watching Nick's stream
I'm kind of like filled with >> I say any of it. We all
know Ethan is so
Nicholas, you knew. Nicholas, everybody here knows that Ethan
just sues people at the drop of A HAT. WHY ARE YOU ACTING SHOCKED
BY THIS? His his >> How do you say he's just telling on
him a little bit? No? >> Nicholas,
why are you ACTING SHOCKED? WE ALL KNOW that this guy is a litigious
that will sue over anything. Why are you pretending we didn't
know that? I knew that. How did you not know that? >> Five-D
chess play. >> It's all Yeah, it's like ego. It's like
I don't know, dude. He built up a lot of good grace because a
lot of people were targeting him for a while and I and I totally
understand that. I just think this kind of tortures it with normies.
Inside your base, this is going to be a big win for you. But
like I think that you're losing the extracurriculars here on
this. >> I think if you file this lawsuit, you'd be insane.
>> Against himself. >> Right. [snorts] >> Very
good. >> So I'm very happy he moved to Canada. I'm glad
to know that we have the best and brightest protecting us in
the
Winter's coming.
>> I'm a woke try >> To be fair, I don't think he'll
actually
I mean I hope >> That is such a stupid argument.
>> And I wish you guys the best. >> I hope he doesn't
fall in like the echo chamber. I know that like the community
seems very gung-ho and positive about this, but I I legitimately
do think this is a tremendous mistake if he files. I really do.
>> There it is. There it is though, isn't it? That There
it is. There it is.
>> This is truly a mistake if he files.
Right? If he files >> True. Ethan Klein keeps threatening
to a bunch of people and he's like, but did he hit anybody?
No, but like he's actually shown truly Well, actually he has
hurt a couple people, but like technically that was like a legal
somehow like like that was a slightly legally justified. Now
he's just like offering he's threatening
Well, but did he though? Wasn't by the way, wasn't that what
happened? Have we not had that pattern unfold a couple times
like hey he threatened to sue these people, but did Hey he threatened
to these people, but did he?
Multiple times they've had to bite the bullet that yes he did
eventually do it. Yes, he did eventually yes yes, he did.